all right this is our second viewing of
Jurassic Park falling Kingdom I am
excited I'm very excited because this
was he's so bad it's good film to me I
thought this was a lot of fun for how
terrible batshit insane it was that was
more Jurassic world for me this this was
so busy this was a trainer this was just
so it got dumber and dumber and dumber
and then just layer things that are
grounding idiocy at the end is just
amazing it just failed on every level
it's such a spectacular degree who not
like there's just too many things that
just annoy me like I hate the characters
to a degree then like I can't even get
fun out of it cuz I just wish their
heads would explode they're just like
it's like twister if like hipsters we're
all the characters of geeks if they're
all hipster who knows maybe you'll be
better the second time maybe we'll just
see a whole new avenue of amazingness
that we just completely missed
to quote Luke Skywalker and Robot
Chicken that's highly unlikely let's
check it out this is Jurassic world
falling Kingdom the fact that it says
Amblin just annoys me all the more cuz I
mean the Spielberg helped produce this
piece of shit yeah he also produced a
lot of transformer movies yes he did
cast Shia LeBouf as Williams all right
so he's losin it we really don't care
where these take place anymore but
they're like 5 Islands louis c.k is
piloting the counter what going like
this what is that name I well what's
this dog
Oh dinosaur
also it's nothing full by now it ain't a
fucking sub what's that little guy gonna
do how does it fucking digest a fucking
sub yeah a landmark technological power
and we've consistently proven ourselves
incapable of handling that power he's
talking about the filmmakers yeah I mean
weren't you in lost world trying to save
these damn things and now you're saying
let him die no I was trying to say sera
sera I'm just like so unboard with this
point of view that oh yeah a movie over
these people are fucking more 100
percent I don't sympathize with these
idiots at all or on what is your job
again you plug in chords right it's
actually more important than it sounds
have you ever seen so many people you
just wanted to punch
oh very mediate introduction I want
punch you I want to punch you and you
and you and you I've gone from corporate
beds to hippie yeah we do
my god you ever went out of color other
than white even he was smart enough to
know okay I'll be in this one I'll be
John Hammond but you got to kill me by
the end of it I am NOT in a goddamn
another one of these I signed up before
I read the script now I've read the
script you're writing me dead in this
you gotta kill me and you know what I'm
not even standing up that's his daughter
died in a car accident
that's awful no no no no I mean the
exposition the way he said that we wrote
that in that's awful who fucking builds
a house with a hammer and nails no nail
gun none nothing - is he fucking Amish
and look at the wood back there so he's
chopping his own wood on-site and Rob
we've both made our own houses I know
more single-handedly I mean come on I
think it was right then and there where
I'm just like oh we're in big trouble
no I'll tell you where I knew it that's
coming up right there right there I'm
like dead you're dead you're gone you're
gonna twist through the shit out of this
really just shooting star that just just
this nice it didn't a shooting star
it'll be magical they're generator
running outside where's my power for
this place I mean he wouldn't use that
power to get like you said a nail gun or
anything like that just still hammer a
nail or nothin else or like they died
riding off for
in a plane no I'm not every time I see
them I'm just like punch punch it's like
wacky hipster wack a hipster we say
looking very hipster is the more I think
about I like it feathers before what's
there to be scared of in the sea on the
statues gonna come alive the dinosaurs
are alive like her so she's like part
dinosaurs ah that must be a if there's
somebody I feel sorry for it's this kid
because she's not a bad actress it's
just such an awfully written character
like was anybody on this kids side at
the end I don't think so like that was
someone like everybody said like that
girl need to go jail yeah why couldn't
you just take your right-wing military
asshole trope here shoot these dinosaurs
and get a DNA sample and then go back
and not have to bring the dinosaurs with
you I know they want to auction them but
just wreck them again and then auction
em Rob Rob they only have enough money
to make a gigantic auctioning torture
chamber under the guise plays without
him knowing and totally soundproof and
nobody can find it they don't have the
money to make other dinosaurs back dr.
Wu costs too much it's just like
siphoning off all that cash let's pray
they put it between the teeth tattooed
guy who's a big buses in he's explained
it's like he's got glasses nice Jimmy
Buffett's Margaritaville ad there hey
have you see how their stock is doing
that is what they really look like now
here let's bring the one dinosaur
doctors never worked on a dinosaur
really Dallas Brice Howard Houston
Austin Texas whatever you could have
picked somebody in dr. Wu's torture camp
who had formerly worked at the park just
Liza's a saw fit to speak snows let's
see like a million studies of dinosaurs
this park my vertical every day knocking
yeah
she likes my pictures on Instagram okay
we're like this after you tiger
hahahaha shout him it wants to be this
movie we're nerds saved the day but in
the end I think nerds destroyed the
world so I don't know well maybe thought
occurs to me I suck at this everybody
I'm just gonna call it you made a
mistake
I like how Raptor training is basically
like George Costanza trying to stop a
truck from running over his fogger
machine you would think a dinosaur would
be smart enough to look at lava and go
no yeah right there lava by the way I
like how it's just like five is like wow
that just hurt a bit lava like it's
fucking lava
yeah it's lava is like just be stings is
that what lava is damnit I knew they
should have made the dinosaurs lava
resistant yeah go up go up
don't turn around go up just go up you
guys a coward you suck oh they did that
literally Miley okay my least favorite
trailer cliche of all time so the mummy
was my lessor is is my father's gonna
kick your cocoon like and this movie
just did it not even extra in the
Wrangler it's naughty we can't offend
the children as we have a little girl
unleash holy hell upon the world
I only run the park I don't know how to
open this thing literally the only good
scene and it doesn't involve dinosaurs
yeah this is the only scene where I'm
just like this fucking terrifies me get
out of the way I'm gonna shoot us all
we're getting out of this picture okay
I'm sorry I blew more holes in this
probably wasn't wise Sandra pollen from
gravity comes up oh hell no I'm not in
this movie friends this is important I
know there's a volcano but I need my
tune everybody stop I need my tooth it's
part of my villain motivation okay yes
die die die die try to tell us a second
I go okay and I love my place up like
this is what it's all about
no I don't care oh those poor things
they're gonna kill us at the end of this
I'll tell you though this is the best
metaphor for the movie because that's
the franchise yeah they're a
brontosaurus crying out in anguish as
its engulfed in flames and an audience
watches really sad probably depressed
and empty inseparably drawn to war and
is willing to use any means necessary
commentary commentary allegory allegory
humans suck what if he doesn't find a
vein oh we got a whisper cuz none of
those other dinosaurs are making noises
and when your movie sucks this hard and
then tries to make a political statement
right your side look yeah no no it
doesn't like make a good movie first I
would never vote for Trump but I would
tell every single one of these
characters I did just to piss them off
not a likeable character this whole
movie
side of Jeffco booth and that's how bad
things have gotten it's the only likable
character do you really think you could
get away with it
in my own house where I come to play
with my toys I want you to call the
police yeah yeah I love that the police
are already called they're on their way
they're outside right now you never
thought about the applications of your
research or oh I totally did I just
thought I was gonna make money off it
yeah all right I'm horrible person I
already knew that I guess like when I
saw this originally I just thought no
she looks like a mother it was so stupid
even when it was shown to me I couldn't
comprehend yes my god I wasn't putting
it together cuz I'm yeah she looks like
her mother and she's seeing her like I
thought maybe she was like the
grandmothers something like that you
wouldn't go to oh yeah she's obviously a
clone of the mom yeah cuz it's just so
fucking dumb now that's odd Cass yes
kind of you and your cat has rejected
this is hey kid you want to come down
out of there let me rephrase that you
want to come down out of here
my name is Claire what's yours Maisie
but my grandpa called me Cologne II
never understood it designed by mr.
Henry wolf don't say my name what the
hell is supposed to be about of us I
don't know why I suddenly was see the
boy from small one bring up his doggy
now here's an especial killing machine
who bar
did they have like a ton of guns and the
guys like cool still a boring design - I
thought I'd be you can make any dinosaur
you want and you just make a big Raptor
every single time and something can play
something uses to make fun and so
Network the puzzle and then what my
stapler give me back my stapler I love
that shot básico we had a few cool shots
honestly but I kid you you you are all
working for me from now on you shall be
known as my Wu Tang Clan the outside in
case you forgot existed
thank God this brilliantly crafted
military dinosaur is dumbest shit yeah
can't find them there what the hell oh
my god it should be so easy how is this
so hard
[Music]
it symbolic as of like a horse
what why is it taking so long
wouldn't just fucking eat her tits she's
not hiding
no it's got fun even as adults I'd be
like fuck these things but the little
kid literally her first encounter with a
dinosaur is trying to be eaten by this
fucking thing
yes what's your point
would you like that fucking dog just
because multiple dinosaurs have tried to
eat her that doesn't mean that they
don't deserve a little TLC - okay the
movie still was sucked hard but would
you give a little bit of credit if they
went that ballsy it just killed them all
you know hell yeah and no way to stop
the gate from opening once it said
something like my garage door opener if
you tap it twice
it starts closing and they can't figure
out I'd do that with a fucking gate and
nobody stops her like literally just
just fucking tackles her and then starts
hitting all the other buttons to try to
close it they just sit there and watch
it like assholes like fucking assholes
should I do the roar okay for all time
bitch hate ever look at they keep it
just like a little bitch
I feel bad cuz it's like it's the Lando
thing cuz like she's a fine little child
actors I think you're he's gonna look at
her just like how could you welcome to
Jurassic world
so finally we actually get a drastic
world at the end of the second of the
fifth Jurassic Park movie the second one
called Jurassic world this should be
where this fucking movie started started
World II feel like it was so splay like
people you loved it or hated it like
with this way it's like people you hate
it or they're like great yes I get it a
little bit because I did like Jurassic
world but I thought that was better
trash than I do like people like
Jurassic world I didn't like it but I
understood why
this one I can't get cuz it's so dull
and boring and swim there's nothing in
the other one happening make no sense
like every second people do stupid
stupid stupid things but any person
would be like why are we doing end where
it's so terrible that it's kind of for
the the twist with the girl the girl
releasing them at the end and the the
cartoonish Raptor that smiles and fakes
out to be the dumbest choices of the
bustle shake characters but it's not bad
Mortal Kombat annihilation hilarious but
but I I'm related back to like you know
early nineties kids movies you know like
those same bad guys those same heroes
the save no firemen worry enough like
dolly shit go for broke in making our
rated Jurassic world already like that's
about it and till then welcome to
Jurassic world following Kingdom to see
what am i doing the oppressor you do it
so much better
why are you trying to rain on my parade
III I was one who was paid money money
to begin saying it for for two minutes
two whole minutes are you really are you
really gonna come by two minutes -
that's it - fuckin
you